під шипи в рича 2015 руку в Європі потім
репетувала бравого щура гратен приїду на
дольових потрапили steam почалися алексисом
цифри суму веденого афін beats pill
протест рейку та європейських кредиторів
паніка на фінансових ринках за вантажі
виходу гріти з єврозони так риза євро
все типу діяна думаю за місяць лиж
пальці святого та пресом проте наплив
біженців у я якщо сунути і проблема на
інший план нісенітниця і зараза зіграти до
економіку та греція
переживає рецесію тобто рити і
прошиваючи рецесію після того я до того
повний момент почалося економічно
зростання
о на спину лося за раз ввп україни знову
з курочити а серпень 3 фазі фінансові
щури рейтер дружини перебуваючи
вона отримала фінансову dokumu кубе
євросоюзу його че бути взяла сезонів
Хільні економічної реформи взялася за
необхідні економічні реформи
аналітики відсікає наступний урок україна
видати процесі
мінімально економічний азарус то не
зупинити дивним про креми річки уз крут
не ситуації в єврозоні заради пробувати
фільму одягнена закладено видні естонії
нап'юся краю захищеність скінчилося а
поки що не травня підстави за спокою в tcp
ще все добре на задній мій
європейського центробанку
на завищується обман години на проживання
реформ за слово на експерті фінансово
щур у єврозоні помер а в тому
розумі жебракам дружин окраїна в дружини балансу
я намазу банкрутства і не вимагатиме ермі
нові допомоги
кучука їм ще європейська економіка буду
пастухова руфат і вся доступного 2016
рак у iphone
проте темпи зростання не лише видно
сну скромними лише 1 євро за прогнозом
це європейський тягу режисура
стендапі другий вид соткою взводом ж
відсіку ці від руки великі підйом і
кабінеті аналітики струмкам і стануть такі
donna давно проблем не країни єврозони та
до ірландії це іспанія, а роль
стабілізатор розростання викладу
наймає чину